oh yeah I'm sure oh my friend call me
cherry so you can find me online with my
social media presence over there and get
help if you're interested so yeah I'm
going to tell you three things about
chapo today because chapo is like a
really kind of new thing I know that you
know a lot of companies are using chat
board and or try to use chapo - so that
they're more like oh we're like AI you
know very smart and but how difficult it
is to actually make a chapel happen and
what we can do with chat bot and we will
discuss it later in the in this talk and
so yeah a little bit about me I'm
organizer of London Python sprint and
also the AI claw for gender minorities
so yeah the London pythons brains we
trying to get people get around to
contribute to open source project I
think is a great great opportunity that
you to learn about for example some
libraries that you use for example
pandas you use it a lot but you never
look at the internals and how things
work it would be a great opportunity for
you so please find us on Meetup you will
find as you know posting events also I
did some contribute over source
contribution which thanks for yeah being
you know at this ring so I learned a lot
so and also this year I just started to
create a new package that is available
on pi PI it's copying MMX if you're
interested you can google it as well
it's on pi PI and also get help yeah
enough about me
so oh I'm like this yeah so so yeah
there's a research so I there's a really
good medium post that kind of talk about
that a chatbot by the osmotic scenery is
a computer program designed to similar a
conversation with human users basically
it's like a boat that could chat to you
so this is how I understand it and also
people talking about this Turing test I
heard about it when I was in primary
school secondary school it's like a long
time ago people already talking about it
so it started
in 1950 so of course it's proposed by
Alan Turing like you you heard about you
know keynote speaker today actually
works for the alan turing institute it's
named after him as well it's a very
famous British computer scientist or
mathematician I forgot but yeah but he
contribute a lot to what we have
nowadays so really appreciate and so
this test he proposed is like if we can
peel a chatbot that the computer can for
the other end of the conversation for
example if I do this test and there's
like given me an interface I could you
know do some on edge head so whether I
could distinguish the other side of this
conversation is it the chat board or is
a human this is you know online chatting
to me so that's the Turing test so if a
chat bot that passed the Turing test
that means that it could be like imposes
a human so that mmm very scary so of
course we for the Turing test I think
now we are not achieving that like yes
there there boss that you know people
claim to pass the Turing test and also
they have chapel that's really close to
passing the Turing test but of course
chapel in the business most of the time
that you came across they are not that
smart and also they're not meant to be
that smart for example of course
everybody was very very excited when you
know this like a Google assistant that
you know I was presented so you can say
like oh hello Google okay could go and
then you can poke a hairdresser
appointment so yeah I remember the next
day I go to the office everybody was
talking about it it's like super
exciting it's like oh you can call and
then without talking to a real
receptionist you can already book your
appointment so um that's really really
smart and also in China you know China
now use a lot of AI and you know
technology for this company WeChat that
is basically like a China version of
every every social media that like you
know like Facebook Plus Instagram Plus
was that plus everything so yeah so this
company they could you
you have a checkbook that you could call
a taxi or even send money to your friend
I was like well is it Barry is it is it
a safe like you can just tell you know
talk to a chat boy so could you send
like a thousand pounds to my friend I
won't trust it but you could try I
haven't try it I haven't been to China
Aegeus if I don't know
also these raffle ooh that cuz I used
refereed card when I go abroad is for a
convenient and so I remembered my last
trip to Namibia was like having some
problems you get some cash from the
machine so I try to ask for help
and then I I go to you know you have the
app and go to like the QN like you know
support customer service and then oh
please help me I all we need to get cash
but I realized that like very soon they
actually I'm talking to chat board so
we're like and then and I my next
conversation was like okay I talked to a
real human yeah so this this [ __ ] but
everywhere and sometimes you wasn't
paying attention or you didn't notice
but like yeah so it's it's really
popular right now okay so the three
things that I want to talk about chat
board is first of all the main component
of a chat board because like everything
started when I try to be a chapel myself
and then I I start to know okay what do
I need to build a chat board so
according to these this blog post again
another propose the biggest thing they
put it very no structurally and I want
to borrow the this structure but of
course we have four main components this
one there's like natural language
processing part so it's very important
because you know you you chat BOTS need
to be able to communicate with human
basically you need to understand like
each other human you want the other
human to understand what you're saying
right so this natural language
processing power sometimes no call NLP
is like it's actually the unit is called
an hour users because it's a natural
language understanding because you know
when the news a type of message the
sharePort need to know what are you
talking about what kind of Matt like
what kind of conversation you're talking
about for example if you say hallo then
you the Shepherd knows always a greeting
if you used to say oh thank you very
much bye and then the
the chapel knows that is a it's a
goodbye and is the end of the
conversation and also entities which
like for example some chapel they need
to get some information from you so this
energy apart is really helping it's
really the depart that you know a
shepherd could understand the
information that you gave to the chat
board for example if you ask the user or
what's your contact number and then the
user so my number is so the the chapel
understand ok the users giving me his or
her phone number and maybe I should
really capture that and do some
following up actions also there's like a
dialog manager which basically is to
control how the conversation goes
because a lot of the typos that use in a
business they have a purpose it's not
like it bought that you know do some
small talks and she chat because you
were like there's a reason why this use
is talking to Shepherd right for example
need help like the help desk or book an
appointment or even you know anything
but there is a purpose so so you want a
dialog manager to control the flow of
the conversation for example you want to
maybe first click greet the user saying
hello good afternoon or good morning and
then you have to know that okay how can
I help you today so you want to know
what direction the conversation should
go and what you know what the user wants
so you need a dialog managers manage
that so the the talk would be would have
a meaning also the content of course
nowadays like most Chapo is not small so
smart that the content like the the
feedback or the the conversation that
the chat pod the word that the trip was
saying is not generated is actually it's
pretty written with scripts so usually
when you bilge headboard you have to say
that oh if you detect a greet instance
you have to reapply by maybe saying
hello back or colleagues at the time of
the day you say good good morning or
good afternoon so need to be pretty
written so it's that's called content
and sometimes what some chat box you
integrate it with other functions like
for example
you want to collect the information from
the user you may want to store it in a
database so that would be some other
external features that you need to
program or engineer also like for
example you want to prom some external
information we'll use let's say the
users asking for the weather in the city
and you want to know okay maybe faster
the weather information from a website
to prompts it back to your user or
recommendation of restaurant you can let
you know also permit back to the user
also what I've tried to do is do a
sentiment analysis of the input of the
user that could be done as well there's
a lot of things that you could do this
option is endless so now to do to recap
you know that there's like the component
of chat bot there's like machine
learning involved you know like Oh
building an hour you is like an NLP and
maybe it would involve some deep
learning and like language model and
also you have to be able to burn out to
develop it also when you deploy the
board you have to know how to deploy
like a for example web apple like a
usable you know application or maybe
hooked it with a slack or hooked it with
Facebook whatever also there's some data
engineering involve as well if you want
to collect the data and store it in a
database and how you orchestrate and how
you got to use this like store it so you
can use this data afterwards this
requires some data engineering legacy is
the teamwork really if you want to be a
chap off from scratch it's really really
hard and but luckily we have some tools
available it was like of course you have
heard about different you know machine
learning tools there's available by
different companies so which makes that
now everybody can actually build a
chapel um which I would also give me
information later
so the second things that I got to tell
you about Shepherd is like what the chap
what can and cannot do like the at the
beginning I said like okay we have this
touring tears but maybe a lot of sport
that now we came across it's not it's
not positive during tests because maybe
it's not what we want the chapel to do
so so what a check
can and cannot do like if we won
something can we really be Chapel to
achieve that so I have come across this
pose it's about why Chapel fails so who
has come across a really horrible Chapel
that you rather just you know click over
uniformed
yes a lot of you so yeah why a chapel
like you know now you know we have
machine learning deep learning and our
people
why chap what is so horrible it's like
we can you know make make a you know
decision you know be also some you know
machine learning to make decision why we
can't have a chapel so I it was like you
you can also you know go to this to have
a look but I gather some you know some
points and also at my own opinion so
first the chapel are trying too hard to
pass the Turing test as I said before a
chat board because like a lot of the
time if a business usage headboard they
have a certain purpose and for some like
if some of the bad design shape or that
I've came across it's like they pretend
to be human but like but they're not
like like the shape or that I used for
or let's say to helped us that I talked
about it's like after a cup of
conversation you would know that is you
are talking to a board and then you feel
like don't pretend to be a human I know
it's a chat boy I don't want to be fool
I'm not stupid and also some of the chap
or they handle too many things at once
is where a boy is a human they have a
certain purpose and they shouldn't be
able to okay they shouldn't be able to
do some like she checked with the the
user and they'll also find out the
weather and also find the recommendation
for a restaurant and also do the booking
I think that's that's too much even you
know Google I think maybe if Google you
know have that money and the resources
maybe they can do something like that
more closer to that but I think most of
the time if we build a check board for
our company let's say you should have a
certain purpose and shouldn't be
handling handling too many things so
yeah a lot of times like people like
what I did is like I end up like can I
talk sorry real human or what button and
oppressor I can really like all the core
real operator on the other side of the
line so well wishes defeat the purpose
of Shepard you want like to kind of
maybe make it more efficient for her
user
you know for company to interact with
their customers without hiring like a
pic you know a team of people who handle
the calls and stuff so yeah I think it
would be better if we just like made a
tripod that we can kind of make it clear
that you're talking to a chat board so
it's gotta be that way and you know you
you lower your expectation also lack of
the clear dialogue flow a lot of the
time that as I said there's the board
there's a purpose and then the best
design ones are the ones that you know
it's very clear about what I need from
you for example if you want to book a
table in a restaurant well I need from
you maybe how many people when are you
coming any you know people would need
special dietary requirements or these
stuff and also maybe your contact
information so um yeah the tripod needs
to like handle it like for example me to
get the information one by one so okay
if you tell me a bunch of things maybe
I'm lacking how many people are coming
then I know that I have to ask or how
many people are coming how big a table I
need to book for you and also minimize
the cheat L is again
chapo is not for chitchat if the chapo
is for how people do pocket a but the
the the the restaurant then like you
shouldn't be talking about the weather
right well maybe maybe a little bit like
because there's outdoor seating but
maybe you shouldn't be asking you how
are you feeling today do you want to
book a cheap he appointment as well
no because I'm running a restaurant why
would you I booked a GP my appointment
for you so yeah like minimize that she
chair try to get the job done and also
what you say if they know that they're
talking to a chat board they they they
actually the user adapt how to
communicate the chat bot that's very
funny and but but I think that works
better than a user getting super
frustrated because they don't know that
they're talking to a chat bot they don't
know how to handle the conversation so I
think that would be a better choice also
some some check posts they are not
they're not there they claim to be not
smart enough
why because maybe they have not enough
training data so they have a bad
you model so it is not really working so
it's like you have checked off that ass
a lot of times like sorry I don't
understand could you repeat sorry I
don't understand could you repeat is
that
oh this chapo is rubbish it doesn't
understand what I'm saying
hmm also not enough content delivery
like diversity like for example as I
said there you have to script every
single reply from the chat board if you
only have one replied and it feels
really dull for example if every time I
say hello to the chapel the chapel would
only say oh hello what can I help you
so it's against every time that hello
what can I help you you feel really
robotic I mean like a chapel of course
it's a chat board but the thing is like
we try to make it to it's more like a
smooth conversation but it's more
similar to a conversation between two
humans so it is too repetitive it's
still you know not not making it a good
user experience also it avoids making
this decision tree like the best part
like out there is usually they can
handle you know decisions like you know
they can for example booking a table you
can tell the chat board first like oh I
have sex people or you can tell the
chapel first like oh when I'm coming but
the chapel can still handle the the
conversation but some of the chat BOTS
they have the decision trees like they
had asked Oh first of all how many
people coming okay and then like what
time and then like well if you your
chapo is doing that then it's basically
you can ask the use of the frame foam
and it's maybe faster and easier less
frustrated so to sum up what are the
good ones like the docs are happy
because the chat was good so yeah of
course we need a good NLP capability so
like for example as I said there's I
have news that I can endure in my Mac I
am a new Mac user I'm loving it and I
discovered that in like using Mac if you
go to the Canada I want to put down I
have an appointment and meeting I say me
think join for coffee like today at 3:00
and if you just write that down
I Canada we just put in your appointment
for you you don't have to fill in like
manually fill in okay free for one hour
meeting atlas
imitating pause and you don't have to
put all these down you can just type a
sentence very natural language ish and
then it would do the thing for you so
it's a really really really good example
of what the NLP capability need to be it
could be just like a very natural
sentence but the port is able to extract
the the entity from that sentence and
that example is Gmail I use Gmail a lot
and then sometimes you know people tell
me like oh please remind be reminded of
your appointment tomorrow sometime
sometime and then Google will highlight
it for me so like for example you
highlight the address so I just click on
it then I know that where do I have to
go which is super convenient so those
are the good NLP examples also you need
to know that they are checked in to
chatting to an assistance
I bought not a human again don't make
your user having high expectation that
they're talking to a customer service
person they're just talking to a
customer service assistance and the user
will adopt like how they should talk to
this thing rather than you know doing
all this chitchat like oh hello how are
you thank you for your help and you know
like just just just talk about the
important stuff also be clear what you
want from the user like yeah just don't
try to do a lot of chitchat just to look
smarter pass the Turing test or whatever
also affects out gracefully and so of
course the Shepherd will fail because
you know a chap what is their pod so
sometimes it doesn't understand what the
user is saying but you can maybe like
just me a little bit more smart and make
the conversation to redirect sure what
the port ones rather than oh sorry I
don't understand could you repeat oh
sorry sorry I don't understand can you
repeat so or even like you want to ask
for repeat you can ask like what
specifically you don't understand like
oh so do you mean like so how many
people are coming to this restaurant
rather than oh sorry I don't understand
so that's much better
so the third thing I would like to talk
about it's like which want to use us
again as I said before that you know we
have all these you know it's difficult
to build a chapel from scratch so most
probably if you want to be
you will need to use one of the the
already builds framework there's
available so I used a lot Russia because
I love open source
I'm almost all phonetic prison so rather
is an open source project I know about
it last year and I went to talk and then
somebody was talking about it of course
like other open source project it has
the communities community support so
there is a rouser community forum you
can ask questions and it yeah so also it
could the good thing I like about it
it's fully customizable so you can build
like what what language model you want
to use so in the raster you can I've
tried different like to too many
different type of pipeline you can use
spacing models so if you heard about
spaces a national language tool so it
will help you know like yo you don't
have to provide lots of training data
it's kind of more like a featuring model
so you can help you to understand for
example is that like a person or is it
like so what interns are what entity you
have in the conversation and also you
can choose to have tensorflow backend so
you can have lots of lots of training
data to to customize for example the
example that the raster documentation
provided is if you're building a chat
pod for let's say a bank or financial
service so balance could means that how
much money a user have rests like in the
account rather than balance you know
like you know like doing yoga you have
to balance yourself to different kind of
contents of the word so if you have some
things very special like that then maybe
you rather do a tensorflow you know
custom trained it's the I think it's a
transfer learning transfer trained model
also you can have a custom functionality
like I said I've tried to build
sentiment analysis with it so you can
add like whatever function you wanted to
use its food like you can even change
the source code if you want but my
think of what I think is kind of neat
it's like it's you have to deploy
yourself because the the open-source
like free version it's like if you know
you have to find a way to deploy it like
online you can also I think they
provided a way to use so you can hook it
with slack and also hook it with other
things like Facebook or whatsapp and all
these surfaces you can have API to hook
it up but um but if you want it to be on
your website for example the other thing
about a way to deploy it excuse me but
now they have a Enterprise version
available so it's more support it's like
you get professional support and all
this help you so you can consider that
if you're using it at work so um Watson
very famous one I think you have heard
about that it's 5:00 p.m. I haven't used
it personally if I've been to their
workshop so far my experience using them
is a very easy to use tool I'm also they
claim that they have a slack community I
haven't used it but I think you can join
if you're using um their drink too much
coffee sorry yeah you can go to their
website you see I think a lot of people
praise it to be very easy to use I'm
dialogue flow is that provided by Google
it's also placed to be for easy deploy
because you know google also provide
lots of cloud services which you can if
you are you already using the cloud
service I think it would be a good
choice if you use it as well so they
have these Google group that you could
again it's like a forum you can find
some community support there as well
they provide a free addition that you
could try out but of course like if you
you know you doing it professionally you
may want to consider the pace you go
kind of Enterprise Edition yeah so thank
you so much
thank you yep yeah I also I I haven't
used it for my person person or work for
a jet but I've been to one of their
workshop that you can so this also
Hoover a speech-to-text Watson as well
they provide a speech-to-text so so I
remember in the workshop there's like
you can't do it so you can say to your
phone so you hook up with this dialogue
flow so you can ask for television
program in f1 so because I did it in
Amsterdam so that's why is the
television program in f1 and it also
support touch which is like of course
like Google they support a lot of
different languages which is good oh by
the way roster they also you can change
the language model that you're using for
example Spacey also support German I
believe so yeah you can also custom me
if you have an other language model but
of course you have to do it yourself is
also require more technical and
resources so lex is another similar
service to dialogue flow and and watson
that's provided by Amazon Web service so
they are also if you are using they
provide lots of cloud service is very
popular for that so if you're using one
of their surfaces then maybe you could
consider integrating legs with that as
well they have lots of SDK so if I
assume everybody's using Python here in
this room but if you used other
languages if you prefer to be reachable
with other languages you can use too as
well they have forum that you could also
have an exchange you know ask questions
and stuff and like most like oh I'm a
sone web surface that you know I think
most know yeah most Amazon Web service
they provide free tier if you sign up
for the first year you can use lags for
limited usage up to a certain point per
month but of course if you build it for
your website or for your you know for
your company then you need to get the
pay you know that you know like Amazon
add a web service it's like how much you
use and how much you pay yeah so
comparison let's put it like
simpler and as I said like I have used
Russell eggs but not that much Watson
and dialogue flow so I try to get some
opinions from other people so this is
another blog post so this is what they
said documentation they said that
dialogue flows has a really good
documentation my opinion about this like
I've used Raza they like because it's
it's open source project and the
community is lovely so I think the
combination is very good and also they
they have these like kind of a tutorial
that you could follow which is good also
a lot of community build tutorial and
examples and blocks legs it's very
frustrating
like most Amazon Web service that I'm
trying to use I think because they are
mainly for enterprise and for
professionals they also you know do
certificates so I think for people like
me wanna try a new service then it's
kind of feel a bit difficult to follow
the documentation so yeah that's that's
my opinion and also this box opinion um
configuration of course as I said Raza
you have to find your own way to do the
host and deployed it so it's feel a bit
like more like need more skills about it
or like deploying it rather than the
others also like if you wanna train it
you also need to have some basic
understanding of NLP and stuff so if
it's more frustrated for beginners or
people who are not so technical Watson
was praised because it's like very easy
use they have all these you know a very
clear diagram of what what component
link to what so I think that's why
people think is very easy to configure
it um for testing they said like the you
know Russa is difficult I don't think
iTunes probably agree on that process
difficult train I think again you need
some knowledge of NLP and know what's
going wrong to be able to fix like for
example what you need to train more or
like fix the pipeline or something but
for the others I think because it's like
I commercially kind of prepared more
though that like maybe people who are
like software developers they can also
use it's not you know for people who was
like NF expert be used though so that's
why it's easier to
they just need to know like maybe set
the purpose of the port and I have to
direct the the the dialogue or how to
what entity they want to capture and and
that's it they don't really need to
think too much about the NLP part so
that's why it's easier so these are my
my my opinion so yeah don't don't be
angry with me if you don't agree we can
have a chat flexibility of course as
that rasa is open-source it's completely
flexible you can add whatever you like
you can even change the code if you
don't want to don't don't want the
original couldn't like anything about
the original code of course for the
others have used legs the thing it's
like I can't change a lot what next you
know even like for entities I was like
this is not how I want them to extract
entities but I really struggle to to get
it done it's not so customizable how am
i doing with time okay okay so yeah for
different how difficult it is like again
like rasa like you have to have unders
you have to be able to write Python code
also you have to have understanding of
NLP and when you deploy you have to F
understanding of you know developed like
deploying a web app so yeah it's not
difficult but but I think it's to the
ref it I love learning new stuff price
of course open source is free like you
can't be that like the others like they
provide a free version you could try but
I think at the end if you want to use it
and you have to of course pay for their
service and the support as well so yeah
you choose so yeah my to say and it's
like before you kind of let's say if you
have an awesome startup and you want to
be rich headboard so you have to ask
yourself what's the purpose of this
headboard so you know that like most
boundary of Jaipur what it needs to
achieve what it doesn't need to achieve
then you can choose what if you for
example if you want a chapel to have
many functionalities and like then maybe
you should consider using Rosa because
it's flexible but if I always it's very
easy I just want to capture some
information
from the user then yeah then you can
maybe use one of the the surface
provided by like legs or Watson yeah or
what resources do you have do you have
already have some cloud surface that you
can you know you can deploy your app on
the instance or you like let's say
you're already using the cloud service
by Google or by Amazon maybe you want to
you know integrate the chat board with
the same so you don't have to cross
platform and all these things so what do
you have and also how you gonna deploy
it do you want to hook it up with you
know um other things like slack or
Facebook then maybe you worry less about
deploying it yourself with browser also
what skill level do you have like are
you how much do you know by NLP how much
do you know about well you know
deployment III can't do web deployment
I'm not a web developer but yeah what
skill level do you have and how much
time do you want to invest in it like
everybody can learn something new and
like customize it fully but how much
time do you wanna invest in it so that's
the question you have to ask yourself so
yeah I think is almost towards the end
of the time thought that I have I want
to make an advertisement about it's not
an appetizer is just like a call about
the workshop that I have done before and
also I'm going to run unconference
session tomorrow at 2:15 which I would
be it's like a helpdesk kind of thing
that you know if you have problems with
these rustle workshop that I built then
you could yeah you could come to find me
but this workshop I can actually I can
show you I have a little bit of time
yeah so this is this workshop is you
know it's completely free it's just I
feel for the community so yeah it's like
it's very self document like so you know
documented you can do it yourself at
home you just need to set up the
environment and you store all these
they're almost free open-source
libraries but yeah I mean like I would
do a unconference session tomorrow so
you can totally if you have any
questions or you're struggling or if
you're just like oh I won't do at home
a lot of things to do at home you want
to have a session you sit down and start
doing it you did tomorrow at a
conference and yeah or pick me find me
on github Twitter and yeah so just just
have fun I hope I hope you enjoyed it
and I hope you learned something about
share for today so thank you so much
[Applause]
we have how Signum i if you could get
the mic and ask the question that would
be really appreciated hey thanks that
was very nice
any experience with Asher but Microsoft
is you're right yeah not that much
experience with that I mainly yeah I
mainly use Ross I have tried to use Lex
before but for the others I have you
know like like yeah listen and I
survived I haven't even been to the
workshop but yeah I wasn't and Google
I've been to the workshop and play
around but haven't really use it so yeah
so really no idea but yeah if you you
have my dears hi thanks very much I
wonder if you had any advice for the
user testing phase of chocolate
implementation where you have you know
presumably some odd results coming up
that you're never gonna be able to you
know cover off all the possibilities of
everything you know and how to explain
that how to like build that into the
project
yes yeah this is the in Ross I score
four per action so of course like you
will you FL like you
so in Rosso the easiest solution would
be if you don't understand something you
prepare like five different ways of
asking the user to be specific and
repeat so that I won't say this like
Huffer out because people know that
you're what kind of screw-up
what I'm saying but is that all just
robotically asking for repeat you can't
be like oh I can see that you may be
trying to book a table how many people
coming by the way you know like yeah I
like just try to make this group it's
just more about for me so I think it's
them all I can ask them technology that
you kind of make the user experience
more smooth than just feeling what
brought it fail gracefully suggestion
right yeah as much as possible
yeah before like wrap your face on the
floor but like graceful least I'm okay
yeah thanks for the talk a question
about I think you said your manager hat
had asked for a chatbot yeah we started
working on this so it but then you
changed jobs so was it a was it a like
at the corporate world and I'm mostly
curious when you're not using GCP or
whatever the other or IBM or etc did you
find it easy to bring in the either the
Russa or any of the other ones into the
job do you see what I mean was it easily
I don't know
accepted given maybe the limitations
that the corporate world might have yeah
I think in the work situation because I
was lucky that I was working in a
start-up the forces so yeah it's like
the structure is very flat you can
propose I assume they have you work in a
big corporate and maybe if you are not
working in an IT department is so
difficult to like even they have you
have this cool idea of let's pitch a pot
and put it at the customer surface
patient on this but it would be
difficult to kind of you know convince
who like even like who is in charge of
making the decision yes like green like
or no then yeah if it's more difficult
so so now it's like now because I
changed job and I now work in a more
structured organization so now become my
my side project we've become but but
even that like because there's a lot of
need much headboard like if you talk to
any like people even if you talk to some
like people working a panel area all
that would be very cool if we can talk
to
the customer and like so I think it
would be good to know how to do it and
yeah and it could be your next job is
you know being a chatbot expert because
I know somebody who get like yeah she's
actually a chatbot expert and she was
hired by a very famous company because
of that and yeah it's a lot of
opportunity there yeah
okay we have time for one more question
no okay then let's think the speaker
again thank you
[Applause]